يتعرض البعض لضغوط شديد شديده فترات
اكتئاب او ذكريات صعبه تثقل حركتهم
الجسديه واحيانا تسبب مشاكل في الاكل في
هذه الحاله لا يحتاجون لادويه للمعده او
تدريبات جسديه لتقويه عضلاتهم بل تزداد
الحاجه هنا لتقويه عضلات الدماغ هناك صلاه
تمرن الدماغ وتقويه لمساعدته على
الاسترخاء
تضم هذه الصلاه المنتشره في امريكا حمامات
البخار بالاشعه تحت الحمراء وكراسي انعذاب
الجاذبيه وخزانات العلاج بالتعويم اما
التمارين فتشمل التامل تدوين اليوميات
ويقول خبراء ان اداء هذه الانشطه بانتظام
تساعد على التكيف مع الضغط النفسي لكن من
الضروريه التاكيد على انها ليست بدائل
للعلاج او العمل مع اخصائي الصحه عقليه
مرخص
المخ هو سيد الجسد والروح من حيث اتصاله
بكافه اجهزه الجسم عبر الجهاز العصبي لذلك
فان اي اصابه يتعرض لها المخ تؤدي الى ضرر
في بقيه الاعضاء يشكل حجم المخ حوالي 2%
فقط من الوزن الاجمالي لجسم الانسان كله
ورغم ذلك يحصل على اكثر من 15% من غذاء
الانسان عن طريق الدوره الدمويه ويعتبر
المخ عضله من عضلات الجسم وتبدا في التكون
منذ بدايات تكون الجنين في رحم الام فذكرت
دوريه جانا لعلوم الاعصاب ان مخ الذكور
ينمو بسرعه اكبر مقارنه بالاناث الرضع
وللمخ مهام كثيره ومتعدده منها التخيل
والتمييز والتتابع واللغه والحساب والمنطق
والاستنتاج وغيرها للحفاظ على لياقه هذه
العضلات يجب ان نتعامل معها كباقي عضلات
الجسم من خلال التمارين كي لا تصاب
بالضمور وتزداد هذه العضلات نشاطا بالعمل
وتتعطل بالكسل ومع العمل يكون الدماغ
قادرا على القيام بعمليات حسابيه معقده
وفي وقت قياسي حيث يحتوي هذا العضو على
ملايين الخلايا التي تقوم بتخزين بلايين
المعلومات
[موسيقى]
على كل اللي في الفيديو ينورنا مدرب
الحياه ومدرب اليوجا والتامل تركي خان
يسعد صباحك اهلا بكم نورتنا اليوم في
الاستديو انا معك طاقه الايجابيه صباح
الخير صباح الطاقه الجميله والايجابيه
اهلا بك طيب صلاه رياضيه للعقل كيف يمكن
تمرين العقل
تاني هذا مصطلح البنت الفيتنس او الرياضه
العقليه هذا بدا يصير دارج مؤخرا وفي
برامج مره كثير اليوم والاعجب انه صار
فينا اوادي وصالات له كمان الان في امريكا
بس هو موضوع يعني حقيقه كامل مع الانسان
من الاف السنين واول ناس بداوا هذه الامور
صراحه هما الصين والهند عن طريق
الميديتيشن واليوجا والتايتشي والتنفس
والاشياء هذه فالعقل اليوم بالذات في
العالم اللي احنا عايشين فيه معجزه الهاتف
والزحمه صار مهم جدا فتلاقي الواحد ما شاء
الله بيخصص وقت يومي او اسبوعي للجسد
العقل وما يدري انه ما يدري انه هنا في
شيء اسمه جهاز عصبي لا ارادي اصلا بياثر
على الجسم اذا انت ما ريحت بس تركي انت
كنت عم تقولنا على الصين والهند وبلشوا
بالتامل هل تعلم بانه سبقهم الفراعنه ومن
كانوا يستعملوا مثلا دق الطبول على اعتبار
انه يعني هي تحفز العقل وبالتالي تزيد من
الابداعيه بالنسبه لهم كل الحضارات اللي
قادت كان عندها هذا الشيء جزء من حياته
احنا الفراعنه ما وصلنا لانه الحضاره راحت
احنا وصلنا من الهند والصين هو بقى لكن كل
الحضارات اللي صارت فيها نمو ازدهار كانت
تهتم جدا بجوانب العقل واحنا جزء كمان من
حضاره عندنا ترى هو موضوع حتى الانبياء
يعني الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم كان يروح
الغار ويجلس ويختلي بنفسه ويتامل ويتنفس
ونزل عليه الوحي هناك فهذه كانت جزء مهم
لكل الناس اللي حابه تزدهر او تكون في وضع
نفسي متزن يساعدها انه هي تخلط اكثر في
هذه الحياه طيب تركي عندما نتحدث عن
حمامات بخار من الشعار تحت الحمراء كراسي
انعدام الجاذبيه خزانات العلاج بالتعوي مش
قصتها الاجهزه متعودين اليوم
امريكي يحب وياخذوا الشي ويحطوه كذا على
السيستم وتمشي عليه فهم قال لك انه احنا
ندخل الجسد والعقل والراحه
والتنفس كله مع بعض فصار يدخل الواحد
تسوي حمام بخار يسوي مساج يسوي
ميديتيشن يسوي تنفس ويسوي اكثر من شيء في
نفس الجلسه حقته فيقول لك رايح
اناس بس خلينا نعطي شويه المشاهدين
الموضوع من ناحيه علميه عشان نستوعب
بطريقه بسيطه في عندنا شيء اسمه الجهاز
العصبي اللاارادي اوكي هذا بيشتغل على
جهتين يا اما سيمباثاتيك او ما علينا في
الاسماء الاول يشتغل لمن انا اكون غير
مرتاح مضغوط تعبان
هذا شغال عنا جميعا الان وهذه هي المشكله
يشتغل لمن تكون مرتاح سعيد حاضر والحضور
هذه نقطه مره مهمه في وضع نفسي متزن الحين
تصير المشكله انه هذا الجهاز الاراده شغال
24 ساعه فهو عندك الاختيار يا يروح هنا يا
يروح هنا محتار مش عارف وين يروح هو نسي
الاول
فنعطيهم تبس بسيطه تساعدهم في البيت
يقدروا يشغلوا هذه وهذه من رحمه الله بين
انه سهلها علينا ففي عندنا التامل
بس مع عن هاي النقطه لانه عن جد كلامك جدا
ممتع بس انا بقول بالنسبه للتامل من
مديتيشن يعني احنا كثير كبشر مرات منقلل
من اهميه هذه الفكره انه كيف يعني بده
يروح هيك يتامل وحتى صعب علينا يعني كيف
انا بدي اتامل بالطريقه السليمه والله
شوفي احنا التامل خليناه رياضه لانه ما
صار جزء من حياتنا لو انا بدي افكر فيها
اصلا هي الصلاه اذا انت حاضر هي تامل بس
ما بيصير بالتامل بطريقه سليمه انه انت
تكون منعزل عن كل المشتتات حاضر بتركز في
البدايه على التنفس عشان تكون في وضعيه
حضور وبعد كده بتبدا كل ما تجيك فكره تسمح
لها ترحب تجي وتروح بعد كذا بتبدا الافكار
تتصفى انت تتخيلي في اليوم الانسان بيجيله
من 50 الى 80 الف فكره في اليوم ايش بيصفي
وايش ما بيصفي فهذه التامل في لها طرق
مختلفه فواحد التامل اثنين التنفس احنا
بننسى التنفس الله اعطانا رئه لين هنا
عشان نملاها كامله احنا الانسان السريع
اللي عمله سريع بيملي اعلى الرئه والانسان
العادي نصف الرئه في شيء اسمه
تتنفس بوعي انك تملا الرئه كامله وتطلعها
خمس دقائق في اليوم كثيره انها تفعل لك
الفارس
هذه اثنين ثلاثه بالنسبه للناس اللي ما هم
حابين تنفس ولا تامل ان هم يبداوا يكتبوا
يفرغوا الزحمه اللي في الدماغ يكتبوا هذه
المشاعر ويتكلموا عنها والله انا حسيت كذا
صار معي كذا مش يعيشوها بنيه انه خلاص
ابغى اقولها وافرغها واخليها تروح عشان
تقعد
لازم احكي احكي
بس اهم شيء مو كل يوم نفس الموضوع
شكرا جزيلا انا يعني من الناس اللي
بيحبوني لما يمارسوا التامل يروحوا للبحر
هل في اماكن معينه تنصح فيها الناس
للاسترخاء يعني شوفي في الكون له طاقات
سبحان الله اعلى طاقات تساعد مو على
الاسترخاء ترفع من يعني من وعي الانسان
ومن حضوره الجبل وبعد البحر والطبيعه بصفه
عامه بس احنا لا نعقدها الا ما عنده جبل
ولا بحر ولا طبيعي يعملها في البيت فحقيقه
انت قلت
لي عن النقطه المهمه
الناس بتشوف انه التامل هذا نايس تو هاوس
شيعه يعني مو لازم اسويه وما اعرف له
والحو كانه نخبه
ههه يعني هو حقيقه لا هو شيء مهم انه يكون
جزء من حياتي خمس دقائق الى عشر دقائق في
اليوم واليوم احنا صرنا في عالم في
ابلكيشن في يوتيوب في امور مفتوحه وسهله
وبكل اللغات جرب اول مره ممكن زي لما تروح
مره اثنين ثلاثه اربعه عشره هتبدا تلاقي
نفسك حبيت جدا
صباح ومساء اللي بيختار واحد منهم اول ما
يصحى صباح عشان يبدا يومه على الفارس كده
يجي ويبدع في الحياه بس احنا كمان ننووه
للمشاهدين عشان المصداقيه والدقه انه ما
فيش عضلات للمخ عشان الصوره اللي حاطينها
ما هو العضلات هي بس عشان يستوعبها الدماغ
بس هو فعلا اذا انت اهملت الفارسه انفثتك
راح تضعف بعد فتره هذه الجوانب ومثبته
بالسي تي اي
بالجهاز اللي هو
مثبته علميا انه الناس اللي بتتامل او
تتنفس او بتمارس هذا النوع من التمارين
بيكون عندها الجهاز اللي هو ابداعي
والجهاز التفكيري ونومها وصحتها
وانستوى السكر ومستوى الضغط والمتاكو لازم
والحرق افضل بكثير هم ليش سموها عضلات
لانه فيش اماكن بتصير اكتف اكثر لما بتمرن
بتمرن الدماغ او الجسد او العقل بهذه
الطريقه فكانك بتقوي هذه الخلايا وهم
سموها عضلات عشان يستوعبها الانسان بس هي
حقيقه خلايا دماغيه بتضعف والمشكله وين
لما ما تمررينها بتقوى العضلات الثانيه
اللي بتفعل اللي بتاثر على صحتك على
ابداعك على نومك على قلقك توترك اكتئابك
حتى ضغط الدم حتى نبضات الكلب كل شيء
واحنا قاعدين نقول لا هي نخبويه زي ما
قلتي وناسين انه هي مش نخبويه هي بالذات
في زمننا الحالي مع التلفونات والزحمه
صارت انا اشوفها اساسيه لكل احد اليوم
الكثير صارت في المدارس تسويها وفي
السعوديه الان بداوا في الجامعات كمان
يدخلوا اشياء زي اليوجا والتنفس والتامل
والحقينها ان شاء الله في المدارس
جميله شكرا جزيلا
والتامل تركي خان شكرا الى ابراهيم